what does it mean for you the fact that
it's out there in the world you're on
the cover you're the rookie of your last
year
here you are it it's a moment has this
kind of sunk in what this all means
i will tell you this i don't think it
still has fully hit me
um this morning i was literally like
trying to watch the videos because i'm
in l.a so i'm getting it a little
delayed
my boyfriend's in miami so he recorded
yeah good morning america while they
released it for me
um and i was just like freaking out in
my bed like with one eye open i was like
what's happening
this is crazy and like um all honesty
it's i it really hasn't hit me yet it's
really crazy
um i cried like four times in hair and
makeup
uh literally my makeup artist was like
stop watching stuff
yeah get through your interviews and
then watch it
um but no it's just it's really
overwhelming even now
just trying to put together a caption
just to post the image
like i don't have words yet guys i don't
know how i
like i obviously it's amazing obviously
i
feel um i feel
like ecstatic and sick like oh
i don't i don't know the emotions are
high the emotions are so high it's so
crazy
and i'm just really really happy that
it's getting such um such a great
response
yeah and it's uh it seems as if it's
doing everything that it did for me
and just kind of shining a a new little
sparkle of light on the world right now
because there's so much crazy
mess going on um so i feel like this is
just something for people to kind of be
happy about it'll take
our minds off of things for all of today
but tomorrow we're right back to it like
yeah it's in if you really make a good
point because
on your social media you've used your
voice and your platform
to talk about what's happening with
black lives matter movement and
you shy away from it yeah and a lot of
people are if what
should you put out there what should you
not how has the response been from your
fans
um i i will say this i feel like i have
had
more support with my followers than i
have ever had
um there obviously are people that do
come
and say hate and write me very rude
messages
with my uh dms and stuff like that
um just like i deal with anything that
they would have to say negative
about me even just being in a bikini i'm
trying to listen to it
um because at the end of the day it's
not
my place to educate anyone it's not my
place to change anyone's mind
um it's my place to show people what i
believe in
what i believe is right or wrong and if
you want to be
all up for it then be for it and follow
me if you don't
then please get off because i may be in
the mood today
or tomorrow or the next day to tighten
you up a little bit and let you know
that it's not okay what you're saying
um because at the end of the day it is
a situation where people have to
understand
that this is very serious we are dealing
with a lot right now
and all honesty there's no excuse
for anyone just sitting around
and doing nothing because you're sitting
around all day
and you have absolutely nothing else to
do i don't care how much work you have
going on in your life
just as long as it takes you to post on
social media it takes three minutes to
go and sign a petition
it does not take that long so even down
to like
me going to protest and stuff like that
i'm like yeah like
i'm celebrating um celebrating anything
just whatever the case may be here at my
house if we do something small
i'm like that's fine but guys let's
let's plot our phones right now like
everybody i know you've signed petitions
i've had arguments with my friends i'm
like look i know you find them
but let's all take the time right now to
all sign at the same time
like let's do research on one let's talk
about it let's have the uncomfortable
conversations
i've had to have uncomfortable
conversations with friends with family
with everyone um i grew up in a
bi-racial home
so it's it definitely hits me different
um and it's something that i'm not going
to be quiet about and i don't think that
it is a case of um people
people feeling neat i feel like a lot of
people are like oh well you've said your
part
like okay next can you like get like i
get some weird messages where they're
like okay get back to what you're
posting
and i'm like that's fine but you do
realize that there are cases that are
not closed yet there are people do
that do not have justice yet like this
is
ridiculous and i'm sorry it is but no no
i i'm feeling your passion i'm feeling
your frustration and actually your pain
because there's a lot going on there for
you right now how are you coping with
all of it
i'm good okay okay as i say all of that
i am so bad
um no i have i have really good friends
around me
um my parents have been there for me
when i've had to have conversations even
with me
hey i'm in i'm in miami right now
quarantining with my boyfriend for a
month
um i don't feel comfortable going out to
protest here because i don't know if
things may get bad and then i'm
i'm not safe to run somewhere because
people don't know me in this
neighborhood
like thought about everything talked
about everything
um have had really long uncomfortable
but amazing powerful conversations with
friends
um just to where i feel like if anything
this has brought me and my friends way
closer
um it has brought me closer with my
family and
um a lot closer to a lot of people that
may have not
uh known that i was as strong as i am
about things because i wasn't maybe i
wasn't as
verbal or as uh excuse me vocal
as it should have been because i was
younger but yeah
now you can't shut me up so sorry yeah
the fear is gone the fear is gone and
you know you
if you are literally silent then you are
yeah the issue
so it's like i'm not you're gonna keep
seeing it because they
are going to keep being cases whether
the world is still
putting it out there or not like your
black square did nothing for us
you keep going you keep going you we
need voices like you and you
you you are part of change you're on
this cover with kate and olivia and then
there you are
representing diversity and body
positivity it's
all of it it speaks on volumes of what
sport
sports illustrated is actually doing
over the last few years what does it
mean for you to be part of this cover
in 2020 and being that representation
um it's a very overwhelming
powerful um like
insane feeling because as much as i
have wanted a platform it is at the same
time a bit scary
i'll be very honest um but at the same
time
i am very much on now is your time to
speak
like you have stressed i've stressed my
entire career i've been doing it since i
was 13 years old
that there is no reason
um for models not to have a voice and
that was part of the reason why i joined
instagram to begin with because i was
like look let me
let me show people behind the scenes let
me show them
what who i am outside of the pages not
just
like at that time it was like i was so
young and people weren't even like
caring to interview me or anything like
that so it's just let me put out my own
voice
and eventually once you get a following
behind you and you get people behind you
you see
that you have a voice that people are
listening to and now i'm in the position
to where it's like
okay well now i want you to listen to
what i've been up to
during coming like i want you to know
how the protests are i want you to not
just take what you see on cnn that
they're manipulating and putting out
there and like
just being very honest like it's you
have to be out there to understand it
and you have to actually fight for
something or you're going to end up
fighting with me
you know in an industry like this no
you in an industry like this talking
about your experience to say you've been
doing is so
young um were you scrutinized the way
you looked
oh you picked on the way you looked this
way yeah this is even
before the industry like i've yeah i've
had several of my
friends say that you're not black enough
or you're not white enough or you're
you have to be black friends or you have
to meet white friends or
why do you only hang out with this
person or this or whatever
in all honesty i have been friends with
dated been around every
every race every ethnicity everything
and
i love every bit of everybody so it's
not i'm
not one that's gonna sit here and just
be like oh i'm accepting it like i've
dealt with it for so long
i like i've had conversations with some
of my other friends who
are mixed race as well and with the same
thing
mom's german and dad black or
uh and their their mom may be white
or their dad may be white and they're
deaf uh their moms um
black and just letting them know like
look
the situations that you went through in
your life are different from mine
because you appear more black than i do
so it's just a different conversation i
i'm able to walk in certain rooms and
have conversations with people that they
may not feel comfortable having that
conversation
next to a darker skinned woman right and
it's not okay
they still don't understand the things
that they say to me
still affect and still hurt me and it's
really
like it's really frustrating it's really
annoying so sweetie
no no no i i'm feeling it it's a lot
it's a lot it's a lot and i want you to
celebrate
i think people really i'm definitely
celebrating it but i
praise you for asking these questions
because there's
some people have climbed in on it today
but you're like digging and i like that
you're digging even though it's getting
me a little emotional
i like that i like it though i'm getting
emotional too now you're talking about
it i mean i
you know for me i have two daughters and
i had a discussion of racism recently
with them
and it was such an uncomfortable
conversation but the importance of
understanding it they didn't know they
they don't understand it
and now they're acknowledging it and
they're learning from it so for you to
speak up the way you
are is so important and you say it's not
your job to educate but you are
educating as you're speaking to me right
now and it's going to
reflect to a lot of people to hear what
you're saying so thank you
thank you for doing that